here is your chance that as Blake John
Gwen Carson and me what you've always
wanted to know about the show let's keep
it family it's a daytime show let's
start with Bri where's Bree hey Bree hi
guys
so first off I'm obsessed with all of
you guys are like my favorite my first
question is for Carson so sometimes they
kind of like take a lot to decide and
what they're gonna say to the
contestants so my question was which one
annoys you the most like well during
that yeah Kelly takes the longest and I
know this because she just starts well
she has the gift of gab as you all know
so she just starts talking about fast
I do sweat I get so sweaty cuz I'm
nervous because I don't want to go home
hey you take long to you just take
forever to finish it you have really a
thought do you have a second question
for guys okay okay so girls especially
um so I know we can't really like see
your feet while you guys are like taping
the show so do you guys like wear your
shoes because I know I wouldn't because
I hate shoes I'm with you Bree and and
now that I know that you don't see my
shoes I hope now be barefoot together
uncomfortable that's good today that no
be super upset because I love my shoes
and I feel like you are being shown the
whole time
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what these old things hundreds of
thousands of dollars wasted
Davion where you at I'm from rousai
California oh right on what's your
question if you guys have to audition
for the voice what would you sing oh
well I think about the songs I cover in
my show like I do a bridge over troubled
waters sometime I do a really
interesting version of dancing in the
dark the Bruce Springsteen song so maybe
some of those songs that I cover in my
shows are the songs I would do on the
voice sound him you could sing anything
he could sing under fear I'm in tears
would turn towards me Gwen that's I was
my mind actually went blank I was like
trying to go through my brain I'm like I
know that this show would not be for me
like I am from a garage like I'm from
I'm saying I am from a band that was in
a garage that worked my way up like I
can't imagine I'm not I can't imagine
you know it's so funny on this song we
just saying that neon moon
I'm not kidding I've been telling
everyone backstage we love country music
Anne grew up on that song but you are my
favorite voice honestly everybody here I
always feel like I'm between them like
he's actually the best thing I've ever
witnessed in my entire life
[Applause]
like keep up with you guys cuz I mean
you're it's just a turn a lot for tone
and I think you're do a turn for me I
grew up on your middle I was like I
literally have loved you since trapped
in a box that is way more than like I
love your song but what song would you
choose lick it up by kiss perfect
perfect okay
[Laughter]
waiting to say that by the way well I
mean that's kind of a dumb question I've
actually it's like what would I do if I
were in a if I were a vocal garbage no I
really did want to sing why buy any
Linux and no one would let us sing their
song so the first is widel so I didn't
get to but I would sing why buy any
Linux that's what my favorite song wow I
love that I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this